Aux dernières élections européennes,
en deux-mille-dix-neuf,
seulement 1 jeune
de moins de 25 ans sur 4 est allé voter.
Prenez autour de vous, euh, 5 personnes,
et bien sûr ces 5 personnes, il y a 1 personne
qui ne pourra pas aller voter le neuf/06
prochain aux élections européennes. Pourquoi ?
Parce qu'il est mal inscrit.
En effet, dans le pays il y a 10.000.000 de personnes
qui sont inscrites,
c'est-à-dire qu'ils sont inscrites de domicile,
de leurs parents,
sont inscrites sur 1 ancienne adresse,
soit perdu dans les méandres administratifs.
Et c'est simple,
avec 1 papier d'identité et 1 justificatif de domicile,
vous allez en mairie ou en ligne
sur les sites officiels
avant le 1ère mai
et vous pourrez vous inscrire
car il ne reste plus que 15 jours
pour pouvoir s'inscrire sur la liste électorale.
Et il est important de s'inscrire et de
participer à cette élection
car il est
important de montrer qu'il n'y a pas que les racistes
qui votent, qui les riches qui votent,
que les transphobes qui votent,
parce que
les droits des personnes transformées en Europe
par l'extrême droite,
par la Hongrie, Victor Orban.
Donc je vous invite toutes et tous à vous mobiliser,
euh le neuf/06
pour les élections européennes,
pour voter pour des euros, députés de combat
comme Manon aubri,
la lâcher vie d'une somargie,
mais aussi
je vous invite à venir nous rejoindre dans le combat
avec demain à la salle du sey arrosé,
mercredi 17/04 à 19h 30,
euh 1 meeting.
1 réunion publique de la campagne de l'Union
populaire avec nos candidats,
Yuno, somar, gilet H. E, B et Maxime jean-saint. À bientôt !